business is business it's an important
contract for dak it's an important
contract for our organization jack is
the quarterback of the dallas cowboys
he's young and he's going to get
extended i'm excited about the
opportunity to work with dak i've always
been impressed with him are you a 40
million dollar quarterback you tell me
what happens when it happens what's
going to be better signing a new
contract or not having to answer
questions about getting a new contract
probably signing yeah
dak prescott
one of these days shireen he's gonna
sign a new contract we think we think
i still think there's a chance he goes
year to year under the franchise tag
that is one possibility uh but we just
don't know and here we are and the fact
that he has yet to sign a contract just
underscores to me how different he is
than other quarterbacks how sensitive he
is to the business realities and how
willing he is to push back it's it's
hard to push back against an nfl
organization it's especially hard to
push back against jerry and stephen
jones but he's done it there was a
report from clarence hill last week of
the fort worth star telegram that dak
rejected an offer that would have paid
33 million per year in new money would
have been about 28 million in change in
total value with signing that's a lot to
walk away from when you've gotten
peanuts for your entire career because
you were a fourth round pick and you got
a slotted rookie contract that paid out
a maximum of 2 million last year but i
respect the fact that he's held firm and
it really makes me wonder what's going
to happen going forward
well they've had a year that they've
worked on this deal so what makes you
think they're going to get it done in
the next three weeks just because the
deadline is sitting there maybe
sometimes that pushes these deals
to get done but how high are the cowboys
willing to go and how low is dak
prescott willing to go you know if i'm
the cowboys i go to 35 and i say we're
offering you 35 million a year it's
obviously all in new money because he
has no deal now uh but he they he's got
the cowboys up against the wall so the
cowboys say here's the deal it's gonna
make you the highest paid player in the
nfl at least until patrick mahomes signs
his deal and we're not going any higher
than that but i just don't know how high
the cowboys are willing to go
and i do think the franchise tag is
going to happen because i don't see them
getting this deal done in the next
couple weeks
the new money thing bugs the hell out of
me because look and i understand the
agents prefer it that way it makes the
contract seem bigger than they really
are but but dak is in unique position to
understand the difference between new
money and total value at signing last
year when they offer him new money of 33
because it's replacing that contract
would have been replacing a deal that
had 2 million left in the last year of
the rookie contract total value at
signing would have been as i mentioned
in the range of 28. well now that you're
signing a contract from scratch right if
you want russell wilson's deal okay it
was 31-4
at signing not 35. i you know i've been
saying for a while now somewhere between
31 and 32 is the way to go to get this
done but here's the other reality it's
no longer about the market once the
franchise tag is in play that's why
there's every reason to try to get this
done before the tag is applied because
if they pick the exclusive tag sharing
and the exclusive tag would be the
average of the five highest paid
quarterbacks
cap numbers for 2020. it's a different
formula for the non-exclusive tag the
exclusive tag you're talking about the
biggest number possible right now that
number is 33.4 million that becomes the
starting point for the discussion right
because if you're not going to offer me
at least 33.4 million per year at
signing with the understanding that next
year under the tag i'd get 40
well then i'll just take the tag and
i'll play year to year like kirk cousins
that's the risk they're running is that
he eventually says i'm not going to sign
any long-term contract i'll take 33 4
this year i'll take 40 next year oh and
by the way if you want to tag me a third
time it's going to be 57 for one more
year and we saw cousins do it and i
think dak has shown and i don't mean
stubborn in a bad way this is admirable
to stand up against that that that
avalanche of pressure to sign a contract
that the cowboys are offering
it would not shock me if he ultimately
says i'll just go one year at a time and
then the cowboys are going to have one
hell of a mess in 2022.
boy they are and you know it's on the
cowboys for not getting this done sooner
because the price has gone up and up and
up and up
and they should have been like the
eagles and gotten it done last year what
the eagles did with carson wentz they
didn't get it done with dak prescott
that price has risen
and now you're talking about maybe
making him the highest paid uh player in
nfl history and and is he worth that it
doesn't matter what he's worth it's what
the market paid that it is at right now
and what someone is willing to pay you
and the cowboys have to be willing to
pay him a lot of money or as you said he
is just going to go year to year and now
you've got a huge bad situation on your
hands trying to figure out if he's going
to be your long-term guy or if he's
going to do like kirk cousins and leave
after a couple years i mean look at it
this way we're talking about 35 million
per year at signing which would be
not in
exact line with the way russell wilson
did his deal as i said 31-4 is what he
got at signing but even if it is 35
million per year at signing and new
money since it's a new deal for prescott
if he goes franchise tag exclusive
franchise tag for two years that's
73.4 million right
that's 36.7 million per year for two
years that's why he's not signing right
you wait for the franchise tag to be
applied and then you see where it goes
from there i think the real deadline
this is what troy aikman mentioned not
long ago the real deadline isn't the
application of the franchise tag the
real deadline is the start of the
offseason program because if they tag
dak number one he's not going to sign it
number two
he ain't showing up for anything because
his leverage isn't just
the fact that he's finished his rookie
contract and he has the cowboys over a
financial barrel as it relates to
franchise tags
his leverage also comes from the fact
that he can do what le'veon bell did the
first year he was tagged and not show up
for anything
until a week before the regular season
still make 33.4 million dollars good
luck having a team ready in mike
mccarthy's first year on the job that's
his leverage and if he's committed to
staying away and i think he is
it puts even more pressure on the
cowboys to do a deal based on the tag
not based on the market not based on
what they think the market should be to
do a long-term deal based on the tag
otherwise not only does he go year to
year he stays away from everything in
the offseason
and you have to have him there you
absolutely have to have him there you
know ezekiel elliott didn't show up last
year to training camp and got off to a
slow start and i think that was a big
reason that he didn't have the year that
he's had in other years in his career
but that was a running back you can kind
of do without him until he shows up but
the quarterback you have to have him
there and i know they're not changing
their playbook they're they're not
changing their system mike mccarthy's
gonna adapt to kellen uh moore's system
still you need your quarterback in the
off-season program or you're not going
to have a very good season and the
cowboys think they're really close to
having a really good team if he's not
there in the off-season program the
cowboys aren't going to have a good
season they have to have him there
and you know there's a point where just
pride in your own workmanship will take
over you would think where jack wants to
have a big year where dak wants to be
ready to work with mike mccarthy now
look the fact that they're keeping the
offense and they've kept kellen moore
will make it easier for dak than it
otherwise would have been and maybe
that's one of the reasons why they
decided to keep kellen moore and keep
the offense because if you change the
offense entirely you give dak even more
leverage if he's going to stay away from
the off season program training camp in
the preseason but you know look you're
right the cowboys have created this mess
and
now how are they going to find their way
out of it other than writing a check
much bigger than they want to write
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports